night so we get off the plane
all the sudden there's a Monday
night game on let's go there
Washington in Seattle kind of
a funny thing when we were
taking off you know we were
getting
out of Baltimore we're sitting
there on the tarmac I'm going
that's Russell Wilson they're
playing right there Russell
Wilson's playing was sitting
right there on the tarmac the r
dub and I'm going why is Russell
Wilson's playing there
they were playing a DC DC and
Baltimore
happen to be pretty close let's
listen Ezra steaks the L
against the Washington football
team your some of the sound
right after the win
that's pretty awesome how do you
how do you hear that how
you see that celebration that
ride man that's what I'm
talking about and the football
team will always have
an opportunity when because I
got a good defense they can run
the football and they got
a veteran coach that understands
those players in
the locker room Robert bear is a
Super Bowl champ 85 Bears
he's been there he's done that
he knows exactly what it takes
I am pumped up about everything
that's going on
until Taylor heinicke is a
competitor I mean I remember
back to that the game against
the Bucks in the playoffs last
year it's really how he earned
this opportunity to go compete
for the job he's just a
competitor are you guys just
going to leave it
out there I think he gives you
enough opportunities clearly to
win the game and like your
mention that got this great
running game I thought they just
out physical out willed to
even the pass rush they get some
big shots on Russell
Wilson in this game
but Taylor heinicke to me is
just one of those competing
guys it's always going to give
you a chance on this right here
beat the pass rush beat two guys
go make that throw on
the sidelines some guys just
have that factor and he seems to
have something about that to his
game Rob what do you say
when you see from heinicke
I look at it I'll look at the
skill players around and they
got some really good skill
players around Antonio Gibson
he showed us something different
and then he came back
he was running harder he was
running faster Logan Thompson
Thomas is a big tight end
big athletic tight end love him
on Terry McLaurin this is a kid
that has had several different
quarterbacks he's never
complained he's never get old
said all my goodness I got to
go with this quarterback that
quarterback he just continues
to go out there and play
he's one of the best young
receivers in the game they have
a really good offense I got some
weapons on the defensive
side of the ball those big boys
up front Washington football
team with that experience head
coach could go some places are
obviously they still
got to deal with the Dallas
Cowboys
yet. Game with Dallas looking a
whole lot more interesting at
this point Washington is in the
playoffs right now
the Washington football team
hanging on to a playoff spot in
this is this is a team in
Seattle that I'm used to being
that you take a
look at the NFC playoff picture
but you're used to Seattle
being tougher in grittier than
most opposed but she get them
in prime time I got used to
seeing sort of the flight being
taken out of that Pete Carroll
defense what I thought that was
what
Washington did even that a
touchdown Drive the way they're
moving them off the line and
that run game and then
the two-point conversion they go
right back to just hammering it
they were hitting some huge
plays on screens on running
back screens in this game really
an impressive performance as
Riverboat Ron Rivera out
coaches Pete Carroll which is
pretty amazing to go ahead
watch
I think it's a time I think it's
time for a change in
Seattle weather that's Russell
Wilson or whether that's Pete
Carroll is not working out you
look at Russell Wilson he did
not look happy and everybody
knows this all season he wanted
out of city
of Seattle he wanted no part of
being in Seattle and when you
watch him in as a quarterback he
says we have to do a better
job of getting DK Metcalf the
ball your guy that makes over
30 million dollars a year you
have the utmost
respect in that locker room and
you mean to tell me as
the quarterback of the Seattle
Seahawks you can't you cannot
make an adjustment and tell DK
Metcalf to run a bubble screen
a slant a quick out a comeback
something that gets him
involved in the
game you don't want a talent
like that over there pouting on
the sidelines rolling his eyes
and talking negative to other
players because now that's
dissension within a locker and
you don't want that Russell
Wilson needs to be a better job
of stop thinking about himself
and start thinking about the
team and getting his Playmakers
the ball that's when they're at
their Marybeth and obviously
they have to find a run game I
think he had to rush is for
like 16 yards and he was a
leading rusher you have to be
able to run a football you can't
be one-dimensional we see
what's going on with Buffalo
yeah yeah and how does it take
until the very last series that
game you do potentially
game-tying drive that needed
the two-point conversion on top
of it but that was the first
catch that we saw DK Metcalf get
me to your point there's so
many easy
ways to get a freight train like
him the ball into round
little screen quick I'll take a
shot just throwing up to him
for it to be all the way until
the fourth quarter before you
even get him a touching it was
an easy little out
route touch that's a mistake and
I tell you end up losing
football games they don't have
enough Playmakers not get their
best to buy